hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to nether mark the
killer is back again now I've been
actually trying to find a stripper with
lots of people on it but apparently not
many people are playing in the US at
this moment but I got a server with
about 24 other players on it so let's
see if we can hunt them down now I
started out a little bit ago but it
appears to be a kind of Perpetual night
I don't know if that's like intentional
or something is going on with this
particular server that I'm on but
usually it would turn today after a
little bit but right now it is just
night all the time and it has been for
like a good solid five minutes now I
don't know if they fixed the day/night
cycle but I'm actually kind of liking it
stalking thank you
somebody out there I've always wondered
if people can hear me like if somehow my
voice communication is just blaring Leon
and everyone just needs me going ah my
name is markiplier I'm just the biggest
idiot there of a word by the way I just
up Brian reading least recently if you
don't know who Brian Regan is all you're
lucky cuz you get to hear all of his
glory now I'm on the island area I don't
know if that's a smoke from a helicopter
crash I don't think that it is that
seems to be farther beyond the border so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna venture
down south and cross the bridge over to
the civilization side of things maybe
find some people there I do want to find
out what this nether surge thing is but
that one's actually almost over so I
don't think I'm gonna make that one in
time but maybe there are gonna be other
players down there I still have that
skull in the corner of my screen even
though I killed someone way long ago in
the last part I guess that means I'm a
permanent pirate now gay my favorite
okay so when I get across the bridge
other than that I don't know what I'm
gonna do like I said before I don't know
how many more episodes of this I'm gonna
do because nether is a it's a fun game
but there's really not a lot to it right
now it is still an alpha
like a lot of these games they're early
access just meaning that people can
support the development of the game and
play it for themselves but first
objectives go I don't know if I'm
missing something but it seems to just
be shooty shooty bang murder and I like
shooty shooty bang murder just as much
as the next guy but I mean come on I
needed a little more substance than that
at least rust had city building and
whatnot anybody out there does anybody
want a piece of the markiplier it is
actually like permanently night I kind
of liked it I didn't think that I picked
a server that was in total darkness
actually to brighten my room door can
you do up a bit
embrace the darkness alright you babies
want a piece of me got a piece of dis
uor none of this what is that what is
that was a glowy red doodad have I ever
seen a glowy red doodad well I just
never seen the glory red doodad at night
what is this what what is it just a
flare just a stealer okay that's the
butterfly let it be known that
markiplier got startled by a butterfly I
see some lights I'm gonna go to the ligh
anybody want some bullets in the face
totally free I'll steal all your stuff
it'll go be great okay I see a series of
shops over here I'm gonna kinda scavenge
up something something about playing at
night makes me a little more nervous
because I can't see anything
everything's just blanketed in shadow Oh
dad come on give me something glow glow
for me baby glow for me guys it didn't
glow for me I'll meet you outside did
whoa what the
it can me I rat okay I guess it's day
now that's that's delightful all right
and dark again and lighting and dark and
light and dark and light and dark and
light and dark nether dude angles nether
jibba jabba give up na meme na dou I've
been wearing long never go where's cup
of winds go where's come from God
you have leaved hablando haha go Oh
who's that the fire of a downed
helicopter over there who is that the
fire of a helot downed helicopter right
there how do we get past how do i how do
I get past this impenetrable fence ah
there was another way around oh I did
not notice this the first time I was in
here oh you dang dirty rats okay there's
the crashed helicopter I'm gonna go see
if there's any interesting things around
maybe someone would lay a trap over here
I don't know anybody see anybody oh
there's another player over there hi
buddy what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing
you want some blows to the face you do
don't you I start you don't tell me I
didn't see you I star you I saw you you
[ __ ]
you stay away this one's mine
mine my downed helicopter my supplies my
supplies
I don't see any supplies but they're
mine anything that wasn't here is mine I
star you I'm gonna go around I don't
think you have a good yeah
please did I get to kill you're dead
alright where are ya hey ice tire I'm
just gonna leave meleave never come back
buddy
friend how where'd you go where did he
go it was right here mark the killer
wants blood I want blood blood
please little bit of blood just a little
bit like a dab blood of lawn my lip just
put a little bit on my tongue ah come on
I finally come across an unarmed friend
and I can't murder him I thought he
crawled away in the grass but I guess I
gave him too much time to run like a big
baby run it away like a loser running in
hiding like a loser runnin away from
your death like a loser you win this
round smitty werben jaegerman jensen but
i'll get you next time
alright let's go into Bailey's but I bet
that guy came through here just now and
picked up anything useful ah I gotta
kill him I gotta find him and then I got
a murder him dead where did he go
is he hiding in the shop are you hiding
here little boy Schmidty
dd
so many women jaegerman jensen i love
the way that name just rules of the
tongue I don't like it I don't like her
that wasn't the sniper snippy glare that
was the glare of the light I learned
that unless someone is trying to shoot
my head off
hey what's with the gas station with no
convenience store what the hell I can't
scavenge anything whoa what is this
Oh oh god is that a smoldering pile of
human bodies that is a smoldering pile
of human filth
yeah entering a safe zone I wanna be
safe I'm already safe what are you
talking about get out of my hair or get
out of my face that's what I bet stake
I'm not yet everyone ignore what I just
said don't don't don't read anything
into that go to hell
oh hi you're not safe for me either so
don't you try anything
ah come on doggy
ah come on ah come on
head I killed three of them none shall
mess with the likes of markiplier unless
I run out of bullets and then please did
please mess with me all you are hey
there is a douche aspire douche but not
a player douche I'm looking for non
player douches trying to get to the loot
drop - but I don't have enough time I'm
not gonna make it all running out of
ammo I don't like to be out of bullets I
need to shoot someone in the face while
I gotta have bullets to do that oh I
wish I had some bullet oh my god are
those dumb bullet
oh yes there are they're crunchy bet
[ __ ] oh are those of other crunchy fans
aren't they they are crunchy Ben you're
the bane of my existence I hate you and
I hope you died a long time ago and
became another thing whoo
oh my god ago eight bullets what the
hell is baloney this is ten times
Bologna five five six ammo crunchy bins
for the bench I don't have a five five
six gun do I
maybe I do is that my main good oh it is
I got what that was not there before
I'll take it but oh oh I found the magic
place of respawning ammo what's that
travel bag what's a travel bag can I
have that where's that travel bag ah
can't be sold for you Oh care about
selling shares how would that be in the
back of an army truck oh oh we're going
to war but I better take my travel bag
it's any centel's kit
ah come on it's filled with food shelter
and love bring it on [ __ ] or don't
find me that would also be oh you found
me you really found me how about you
about a holdout and you thank you thank
you for being dicks
give me some on this shoot Oh Jill babe
all my neighbors probably think I'm very
deranged
damn it it's gone whatever come on the
answer is all of them that's just a dick
oh I'm gonna whack you with my crib I'm
gonna bash your brains in if you have
any brains you you don't you don't you
don't want to mess go on the plate all
right okay with that I seem to be out in
the complete open
I can't wait for someone to blow my
brains out from afar without em Oh Jeff
Firefox tech demo yeah I just need to
not run apparently running sends out a
message to the beepers of all the
zombies in the area I don't care if
they're not zombies that's why I'm gonna
call them yeah
love do you think oh don't do that thank
you come again
ah piss balls and ass I'm in trouble
aren't I I'm in a world of hurt I'm just
uh I'm stomach so much trouble some
player come pick on me I'm I'm so
exposed I'm so innocently affected by
all these troubles and tribulations I
hope that someone put me out of my
misery someone got me out of my misery
I don't know why I'm still here though
not like the loot drop is just gonna
hang around I don't know I found some
ammo like gas but not a lot I wonder if
the amber lamps does have weapons of
mass destruction in them OOP no just
lots of blood and crunchy bed my Fifi
crunchy pinch all right I can't believe
it my luck is just incredible
I feel good your burns who mo that is
that isn't it now I eat the crunchy
bends a little we're gonna get fat badly
apocalypse whoa think I just got these
bullets that money using a fake eggy on
is that the siren call of a douche epic
soup are high being awfully jumping and
leaping mrs. loo and dad being awfully
dead - that's something you're being I
don't need these [ __ ] do I have to
kill me the highest level character in
all the land apparently okay I
officially decided I have the absolute
worst luck in the entire world when I
wanna find other players
I can't even girl they run away from me
Oh what I don't oh you heard me running
you me right
I'm in here there how about you here
that you're that there's this beams of
your death
that's good sound huh but when I don't
want to find players are crawling up my
own ass well it looks like I killed
every single ding damn nether I've saved
the world you're all welcome you're next
on my list but hopefully you all die
before I get to you whoa what the hell
happened here
don't plug it pundit telephone poles and
crucified a buncha people lovely lovely
love to see it love to see everyone
working together in times of strife I
don't care what I just said ignore what
I just said about killing everyone I see
that's awful how dare they alright
that's it everybody I've been wandering
the wastes for far too long so I am not
dead yet I'm actually very high-level
don't ask me how I keep surviving so
long because frankly I don't know but
either way thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
my dad
Oh
okay
not have this giant right hand for the
devil